today on the matt walsh show the trial
of derek shovin was the greatest sham in
the history of the modern american legal
system
we're now learning just how much of a
sham it truly was today we'll talk about
the juror
who apparently lied his way onto the
jury in order to as he says
bring about social change also five
headlines including jill biden's
that's jill biden's dr jill biden sorry
push for universal free community
college
and also the bizarre story of the child
who was paddled with a wooden board by
her teacher
while her mother watched but now the
mother is complaining to the media and
saying she didn't want that to happen
and our daily cancellation we'll have
something that will probably make a lot
of people very angry i'm going to
explain why
anxiety isn't a real mental disorder all
of that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
now a quick word from my pillow well you
know i've been telling you about my
pillow
you've heard about my pillow not just
for me but from lots of people because
it's just the
the most comfortable pillow that you
could ever use
um and if you know that if the pillows
are comfortable then think about how
comfortable the slippers
must be that's why they're introducing
the new my slippers the slippers
took over two years to develop and
they're designed to wear indoors and
outdoors all day long
the my slippers are made with my pillow
foam and impact gel to help prevent
fatigue and
they're made with quality leather suede
so they're very durable
and like i said you could wear it
outside but they're also super
comfortable for a limited time my pillow
is offering 40
off their new my slippers yeah it's 40
off i
have these slippers myself i wear them
i've always been
a slipper guy at home especially as a
dad you know you got to make that
transition eventually where
you're wearing the slippers at home and
i cannot recommend
these slippers enough to you so go to
mypillow.com and click on the radio
listener square and use promo code daily
wire you also get deep discounts on all
my pillow products including the giza
dream bed sheets my pillow mattress
topper
my pillow towel sets and much more call
800-951-7163
and use promo code dailywire or visit
mypillow.com now or call 800-951-7163
it was apparent from the beginning that
derek chovin was not going to be given a
fair trial in front of an impartial jury
of his peers
if there was ever a trial that should
have been moved to a different location
this was that trial but it wasn't moved
and if there was ever a jury that should
have been sequestered for the duration
this was that jury but it was not
sequestered chauvin was being judged by
minneapolis locals
who lived through the protests and riots
and who were leaving the court each
night and returning to that same
community
likely driving past the angry angry
crowds that were
threatening to burn down the city if a
guilty verdict wasn't
returned to make matters worse and the
trial an even more blatant sham
george floyd's alleged drug dealer who
was present on the scene
on the at the scene on the day of
floyd's death wasn't required to testify
and most egregiously there was no
mistrial declared after a prominent
congresswoman maxine waters
traveled from dc to minneapolis to
demand a guilty verdict in front of a
frothing crowd and call for more
confrontation
should the jury fail to give her what
she wants
it's it's hard to imagine how a deck
could be more
unfairly stacked against the defendant
and that's before we take into account
taking into account the apparent
blm activist who maneuvered his way onto
the jury
juror number 52 who we now know is
brandon mitchell
and we know him that way because he's
been all over the media in recent days
nobody's doxed him he has come forward
himself
been doing a ton of media interviews
he's very eager to tell his story and
receive the applause that he evidently
feels entitled to
but the part of his story that he has
not been quite so eager to discuss
is his own recent experience as an
activist for the blm cause
as multiple outlets have reported
including the daily wire
mitchell was photographed in august of
2020 after attending a rally in dc
in the picture he's wearing a black
lives matter hats
and a t-shirt that says get your knee
off our necks
not very subtle if this is impartiality
i would hate to see what partiality
looks like
mitchell now claims that he doesn't
remember wearing the shirt
okay and that he only attended the rally
because he'd never been to dc
and it was quote an opportunity to be
around thousands and thousands of black
people
i guess there are no black people in
minneapolis or he didn't notice them
he also claimed on his juror
questionnaire that that he he never
participated
in any protests against police brutality
that's what he said on the questionnaire
in order to get on the jury that he
never went to any protest for police
brutality anywhere
what about the event in dc well he says
that although he attended it in full blm
attire
and it was held in the middle of a
summer when protests against alleged
police brutality were raging across the
country
and it featured speeches speeches from
george floyd's family members
and there were people holding signs that
literally said stop
police brutality still somehow somehow
the whole thing had nothing to do with
police brutality that's what he says
it was really just a commemoration and
celebration of martin luther king jr
now anyone with any level of
intelligence might feel that it has been
horribly insulted by this excuse yet
even if you buy the excuse
you still have mitchell's own words to
contend with
in an interview with the uh get up
morning show whatever that is
the former juror number 52 seems to
admit
repeatedly that he was far from an
objective participant in the trial
straining credulity he says that he
didn't know much of anything about the
case prior to
showing up for jury duty apparently he
suffers from amnesia
at least amnesia about the george floyd
shirt he was pictured wearing so perhaps
this was another flare-up
he you know he heard about it but then
he forgot everything when he showed up
for jerry
for jury duty but he also says that he
saw
a small portion of the video depicting
floyd's death
and that after seeing it he quote didn't
need to know much else
let's listen to that prior to the case
did how much did you know about
george floyd and how he was killed i
don't i mean
i had seen like a little portion of the
video but i couldn't really watch the
video like that just because
it wasn't something that i wanted to see
we see so much of
a black man being killed i was like i
can't i can't watch it so i clicked on
it on accident one time
and turned it right off and that was all
i knew really wow
i didn't i didn't need to know much else
though i mean i knew how the video would
end
and that was it you're 31 years old and
i understand you were the only
african-american man in the jury pool
tell us uh about the other jurors on the
panel
if you can yeah yeah yeah so i mean so
yeah i was the only african-american
though there were two other
uh men of african descent um there was
also
a black female um a mixed lady and the
rest of the rest of the cast was uh
was white um older i think it was like
maybe five other white women
and then another another white guy
okay i'm not quite sure the last part
there he's the only african-american man
but there were two other males of
african descent
is it were they not american were they
not citizens and yet they were on a jury
i don't understand what that means
but let's forget about that part he says
i saw a little bit of the video
i didn't need to know much else really
because you're on the jury to because
you're supposed to want to know
what else is going on is that the sort
of attitude we want from jurors
how impartial can we expect them to be
when they've seen only a short sampling
of the prosecution's evidence
prior to the trial and have already
decided that it's all they need to see
later in the interview mitchell
confesses that he went into the jury
selection process
cognizant that it was a quote historic
moment
and a chance to make history as if that
wasn't clear enough he says that
he knew from the gate what it was and
what it could be
now this part of the interview hasn't
gotten a lot of attention i'm not sure
why
because this seems to me to be very
significant let's listen to that
did you really understand um how
important your role was
as a juror especially being the only
african african-american male
on the jury panel yeah so i said even in
my initial interview
to the lawyers that i felt like it was a
historic moment and
that we would have a chance to make
history by being the jurors on that
on that case so i knew from the gate but
it was what it was and what it could be
it was a chance to make history
this is um an impartial jury
somebody on the jury who was there to
make history
offering some closing thoughts to wrap
up the conversation mitchell advocates
jury duty as a chance to
quote get out there and get into these
avenues and get into these rooms to try
to spark some change
here's that part so what message would
you leave to those about
saying yes to jury duty i mean it's
important if we want to see some change
we want to see some things going
differently we got to get out there and
get into these avenues and get in these
roads
um to try to spark some change right
that's when jury duties one of the
things jury duty voting
all those things and things you got to
do okay so to review
brandon mitchell a juror on derek show
of the murder trial
had previously attended blm rallies
wearing a george floyd t-shirt and
admits that he saw the jury as a
historic chance to bring about social
change
he is an activist who used the jury as a
forum to advance his agenda
he's saying that that's not my
interpretation that is what he is saying
he did
in other words this was not a fair trial
not close
and that would be the case without the
blm activist on the jury
that's the situation we're in right now
the blm activist who lied his way onto
the jury is icing on the cake
and with the activist it becomes again
one of the worst shams in the history of
the modern american legal system
and i don't think that's an
overstatement the case for a re-trial
is overwhelming if
if this doesn't qualify for a retrial i
can't imagine what would have to happen
in a case for it to get one
but does that mean that a retrial will
actually be granted no
doesn't mean that you know just because
it should happen doesn't mean that it
will
chauvin was always going to be a
sacrificial goat made to pay
not just for his own sins but for the
sins of all of white america
in fact new reports suggest that the
justice department was standing by
in the courtroom when the verdict was
read ready to arrest chauvin
in the courtroom on the spot and charge
him with civil rights violations
if he had been acquitted they were not
going to let him get away
even if he was found not guilty now even
if you think that chauvin is guilty
how does this rise to the level of a
federal crime
what evidence is there to support that
charge
well evidence only matters if you care
about things like truth
like fairness like justice and this case
as we have seen has never had anything
to do
with any of those things and now let's
get to our five headlines
you know there are a lot of uh
responsibilities that you that you have
to take on as an adult
that um seem sort of daunting and you
you put it off and you put it off and
you put it off
uh until until sometimes it's too late
and putting a will together is
definitely one of those things
but it's so important to have a will uh
to have something there
for your loved ones if anything ever
happens to you you don't want to put
them in a position where you don't have
a will
and um and that's just not fair to them
and here's a good thing
it's really easy to set one up at
trustandwill.com setting up an estate
plan is simple convenient and secure for
as little as 39
you can nominate guardians for your
children you can determine who gets your
stuff and plan
for medical future medical care for
everyone from the comfort of your home
trust and will documents are designed by
estate planning experts and customized
for the state you live in
and with live customer support seven
days a week trustedwill.com
team is available to answer any
questions you have
while setting up your plan make sure you
get that will go to trust and will
gain peace of mind at
trustedwill.comwalsh and get 10 off
plus free shipping of your customized
legal documents
don't wait go right now this is really
important get 10 off
plus free shipping at trustingwild.com
walsh again that's trustedwill.com
walsh all right so uh let's start with
joe biden he gave a speech
about the covid response yesterday and a
couple
of a couple of notable things this one
i'm not really sure if we can call it
notable because i don't know what he's
trying to say
but uh he he's trying to get something
out and uh
and and here's what here's what he
landed on this is what it sounded like
we're gonna make it easier than ever to
get vaccinated
visit vaccines.com.gov
vaccines.com or text to
your text your zip code to
eight two 438829 four three eight eight
two nine
i just love when he when he does the i'm
going to repeat
or let me be clear and then what he says
next
is far less coherent and clearer than
the thing you said before
vaccines dot
you know there's dot something there are
a couple of different ways you can
interpret
what he said it wasn't com
um i'm not going to speculate much but
vaccines.gum
maybe it's where you go for um for
chewing gum
you want to get a pack of chewing gum
you just go to you know
go to that web address i don't know um
but he also had
that was kind of startling it's always
startling when your president
is losing his mind on camera as this guy
has been
um for for a long time now before he was
even elected
this part was startling too where he uh
he reveals
um that death is still coming for us
we can't escape it he says let's listen
you know there's a lot of misinformation
out there
but there's one fact i want every
american to know
people who are not fully vaccinated can
still die every day
from cover 19. look at the folks in your
community have gotten vaccinated
and are getting back to living their
lives their full lives
can still die every day
they don't die every day you know i mean
generally you would hope that you would
die only once
that's a rough that that that's pretty
rough if you could die from covet
every day like you already died
yesterday now you gotta die again today
um or or if he means that that people
just people in general are gonna die
every day if they're not vaccinated
i agree with him and in fact i will say
that he
uh he uh he's understating the case it's
actually a lot worse
than what he just said um in fact
people are going to die every day no
matter what
even if they've gotten the vaccine
people are going to die every day
and i i'd go even i go further than that
and i know this seems quite shocking
almost unbelievable but uh it is true
believe me on this that
everybody will die
we're all doomed we will all die of
something and pretty soon in the grand
scheme of things
yeah you know the amount of time you
have left is measured in
in a few decades at most
so he's absolutely correct about that
people are going to die
every day they will but probably not of
covet that's the thing
whether you have the vaccine or not
especially if you're a little bit
younger it's it probably
it probably will not be covert that gets
you could be probably won't be but it'll
be something
eventually so thank you for that joe
biden okay now um
moving on to this i want to play this
for you this is this is a a totally
bizarre story
out of florida and i think florida gets
a bad rap sometimes
it it's not the crazy state in my
opinion california is the crazy state
oregon is the crazy state even vermont
is the crazy state
um i i think florida is unfairly labeled
that way
although this we're about to play a
local news report for you
every aspect of this is
weird so let's watch what the local news
has to say about uh about this incident
here let's watch
finally you understand what's going on
that's a school principle
put your hands down
hitting a six-year-old with a wooden
paddle in front of her mother
the hatred of which she hit my daughter
i mean it was a hatred that really i've
never hit my daughter like she hit her
i'd never hit her that's her that's the
mother speaking she's speaking spanish
i'm reading the subtitles to you
we know the name of the woman with the
paddle through a report from the henry
county sheriff's office
it says the principal of central
elementary melissa carter and cecilia
self
a clerk are the two women in the video
we tried to reach them through the
school district
but were unsuccessful the child's mother
recorded this video
why didn't she stop the beating mother
says if i had done it with my own hand
it would have been bad for me
i don't know mom told deputies the
school called tuesday april 13th
saying her daughter damaged the computer
the fee
50 in the report mom says the school
also mentioned
paddling with her and a deputy present
in the report the mother says she didn't
understand the process correctly
later that day she went to the school to
pay the fee and they took her into the
principal's office
she already had her there then the
principal started to scream
the mother says behaving and taking care
of the stuff
you don't keep messing up things mom
looks around
no cameras nerves set in bueno
there are no cameras what are we doing
here in this place my daughter and i
alone
so she did what she thought was her only
option
how do i prove if there wasn't a camera
she hit her cell phone in her purse and
press record
okay stop it right here pause right here
we're gonna
we're gonna cut out of the video right
here but but okay so
you get what happened here um the girl
got in trouble six years old
damaged a computer they sent a note
saying that she's going to be paddled
for it and the mother shows up
to be present to be witness to be a
witness at the paddling
but she didn't she didn't want her
daughter to be paddled and
rather than step in and prevent it and
say
hey don't hit my kid she watches it
and films it and this is the reason
she's giving in the subtitles
she says oh my gosh she says i
sacrificed my daughter
so all the parents can realize what's
happening in this school
um so that's why she didn't step in
because she was offering her child up
as a sacrifice
to raise awareness about the corporal
punishment issue at this school
as i said every part of this story is
bizarre i i don't understand exactly
what's happening here well with the with
the mother i think i do understand
what's happening
um she as unfortunately parents so often
do these days
they see their kids as a chance to go
viral and get attention
and file a lawsuit and so if i were to
speculate because we can only speculate
about
about somebody's motives um and so in
this case
when another adult is gonna hit your kid
and tells you they're gonna
yeah she says she was confused by the
process it's written down there like
we're gonna paddle your kid with a
wooden board that's what we're going to
do
what are you confused about here what do
you mean what do you mean
what do you mean with a wood paddle with
a warden board do you mean like
metaphorically
what do you mean by that i think they
were actually
pretty upfront it seems about what they
were going to do
ma'am we're going to be uh hitting your
kid with this board right here
and you're going to stand there and
watch
now if this were me and uh
and i didn't want my child to be hit by
another adult which i wouldn't and we'll
get to that in a second
i'm going to physically intervene like
walk over and say you're not going to do
that
you think that's what any parent would
do if they actually wanted to stop it
she didn't so we can again only
speculate my speculation
is that she saw an opportunity to file a
lawsuit just she says that uh
she she sacrificed her daughter so all
the parents
um can realize what's happening in this
in this school this is like a
some kind of perverse christ scenario
sacrificing
the child is sacrificed um
but i think she sacrificed her daughter
you know if i were to again just
theorize i would say she sacrificed her
daughter
uh to get that big bag of cash from the
lawsuit
so that's the mother part of it now i
got to think about the school
first of all it seems like this is
something that they just do
i didn't know that this existed anywhere
in the country still
i'm i'm actually kind of shocked it does
um and they do this and now there's
controversy
like did do you not know that that's how
people are going to react have you have
you
been in our society for any length of
time
have you seen the way things go you
think you can
paddle kids with a board at school and
it's it
and people aren't gonna be upset about
that
now the thing is you know the idea of
corporal punishment
um i think a corporate punishment can
have a place
in the home i think that's that's
parents have to make their own
parenting decisions and uh you know
children respond differently to
different kinds of punishments
i don't think that there's a
cookie-cutter one-size-fits-all approach
when it comes to discipline and
punishing
and some some methods work for some kids
some methods don't i mean
there are some kids that you can put
them in timeout in a corner
and and and that's really going to get
the message through and
you don't really need to do anything
else there are other kids who they don't
care about that
and you might as well not be doing
anything they you put them in a corner
it makes no difference
so kids are different kids have
different personalities
in the home you can make your
decision about how you want to handle
your kid
at school though no i mean that's what
i'll say i
look i'm old-fashioned on a great many
things
and i understand that back in the day i
mean my own parents will tell me stories
um about this kind of thing when they
went to school
and this is what happened when kids got
out of hand unruly you take out the
ruler take out the
the paddle and you handle it that way um
but now my my general policy here
is um if you're
you know as as another adult you're not
going to lay a hand on my kid
man as simple as that and really what it
comes down to is this is a a power
and an authority and a tool
that i don't trust the school to wield
literally and figuratively i'm not going
to trust the school with that
i think some parents can be trusted with
forms of corporal punishment
um spanking and so forth with their own
kid am i going to trust
the school system am i going to charge a
public school teacher
to be using physical discipline on a
child no
no no no no no no
no i'm of the opinion that the schools
are not parents
teachers are not parents shouldn't act
like it
shouldn't have the authority of a parent
there should be a
a clear dividing line
between parent and teacher
and now you are going way across that
line in my view
so that is simply again that is not an
authority that's not a power not a tool
that i would trust the school
system with government the government
school giving them
you know entrusting them with the power
to hit your child
uh no even if it's not a government
school system private school same thing
so what a story there all right um
let's move on staying in the realm of
education here
staying in the roman fact of bad ideas
in education
jill biden sorry again that's dr jill
biden
made the case a couple of days ago for
free community college
uh i i still have no idea why first
ladies are getting involved
in advocating for policy at all
i don't know why i've never been able to
figure that out why do we need to hear
from them
why should i care about you we you
weren't elected it's not like you're
elected by default or
anything like that you were not elected
but um but you know this is what we do
with first ladies we send them out give
them
their little pet projects to do and so
free community college that's
one of jill biden's pet projects and
this is how she
made the case for it community college
graduates promot
provide more security for their families
they invest in their local schools and
businesses
and they bring needed skills to our
workforce
helping us to meet the challenges of the
21st century
that's why we need two
years of free community college
yep just more we just need more free
stuff that's the way to solve our
problems
yeah they had another the left they had
another brilliant idea
how do they think of this stuff it's
genius
every problem they always they always
stumble on the solution free stuff
give give people stuff for free that'll
solve it
no you know free college is not the
answer um
free community college is not the answer
student loan forgiveness is not the
answer
at least it's not the answer to any
question worth asking when it comes to
this issue
i'll tell you the answer the solution
to the problem and the problem you know
the problem is
multi-faceted but the problem of uh
of the student debt crisis um the
problem of
you know of of kids and and young adults
being required or feeling like they're
required
to spend tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of dollars
on an education just so they can get an
entry-level job somewhere
the the solution to that problem
is not free stuff it is to move away
from this artificial contrived system
completely
that's the solution because the fact of
the matter is
vast majority of jobs in america
don't really necessitate a college
degree
except artificially
the in the vast majority of jobs you're
going to
learn how to do the job once you're on
the job
there's going to be on-the-job training
or something like that that's that's
that's the majority of jobs
that includes high-paying jobs that
includes any kind of
many of many different stable careers
that you could have a
you know you could make a very nice
living in
we're not just talking here about you
know being a cashier at mcdonald's or
something
that is most jobs
where you whether you went to college or
not
you got a start entry level um
and and whether you have that piece of
paper or not and all that debt or not
you're going to go into the job not
really knowing how to do it
and you're going to have to learn like
anybody else so what does the piece of
paper do for you
well in a lot of cases it gets you in
the door but that's artificial
we've decided as a society to require
the degree for a lot of jobs
not because it's actually needed
but because we simply decided it that's
that's the
the left is is always a fan of uh
criticizing what they consider to be
artificial constructs well here you go
here's artificial construct number one
is the maybe the number one example
of a damaging harmful costly in more
ways than one
artificial construct
that you need to have a college degree a
piece of paper that you spend ninety
thousand dollars a hundred thousand
dollars on
to get an entry-level job in a in a
profession that you're gonna have to
learn
on the job anyway
the solution is to move away from that
if we're not going to move away from
that if we're going to
continue requiring degrees for no real
reason
then the problem's only going to get
worse
in fact you start giving out free
college you start doing some form of
student loan
forgiveness um now the pressure to go to
school for no reason
is increased and now you can have even
more more
careers and occupations and jobs and
employers that require the degree even
though it's not really necessary
yes obviously there are some lines of
work
where you need additional formal
education nobody would deny that
you want to be a doctor you want to be
an engineer you want to be a lawyer you
want to be
an architect clearly there's there's
additional formal education often times
a significant amount of it
not just four years that you're going to
need to to get but
you want to get a job you're going to
start start at a in a cubicle somewhere
like entering data into a computer or
whatever you're doing
you need a job in marketing or sales or
something like that
you don't need a degree for that
but nobody wants to talk about that no
one wants to move away from that system
and i think one of the reasons and
most people recognize i think that this
it's a it's a flawed system obviously
but i think people don't want to move
away from it because they've invested so
much in it
and it would feel like unfair to them if
we started moving away from it
but we have to
all right um a couple things here
from twitter that i wanted to quickly
read here's cnn anchor anna cabrera
has this report she says nyc public
schools will have remote learning
instead of snow days next year
according to the new york city
department of education
this was you know i worried about this
for the kid's sake
when we started doing the remote
learning thing that this is
this is what's going to happen it's
going to be the end because now that
schools have decided they can replace
education
with with the computer which really you
can't because it's not going to be a
real education as we've seen we've got
all these kids falling behind
because they can't learn that way even
for adults it's really difficult
to stay engaged and certainly to learn
uh by staring at a computer for seven
hours a day and listening to
a talking head you know spitting words
at you
but because school systems have decided
that it means that you know you're not
going to get days off anymore
as kids so take the snow days away yeah
why not i mean
just just take all the childhood joy
away
yeah we've done that for the last year
closed down the pet playgrounds took
everything away
uh take away you know if kids want to go
to summer camp they have to wear a mask
and stay socially distanced the cdc is
saying so let's just um
let's take every last childhood joy from
these kids let's let's take it away
because as always it's not about the
kids it's about us
right um and then also there's this this
is a great
vaccine psa that was posted by the
baltimore baltimore city health
department
to twitter um so you can take a look at
this
it's a it's a picture of a woman looking
kind of sullen and pouty
and then there's a guy presumably her
husband
sitting behind her and saying mimosas
with the girls you still aren't vaxxed
deborah
this is a this is a baltimore city
health department this is how they're
pushing vaccines and i kind of
appreciate it
you know i i i don't agree with the idea
that you have to have a vaccine to go
out and have moses with the girls
there's no reason why you can't
um but i do like how they are
it seems to be advocating here
traditional patriarchal
male-led households that i can
appreciate for the bottom i suspect they
did it by accident
but still i uh i appreciate it and
finally before we move to the comments
here's a report from the daily star it
says
pretty shocking it says hitler liked
women peeing on him during sex and was
incestuous with his niece according to a
new docu
documentary
see i all i'm gonna say is i always knew
that this guy was up to no good
i'd been starting to get a bad feeling
about him but this really confirms it
you just never know you never know these
days you never know
all right let's move now to uh our five
comments or not five comments i don't
know how many comments we're gonna do
i'm mixing up my segments now this is
from donna says hey matt as far as
prince charming goes
what he did was perfectly legal if
you've ever taken a cpr class there is
something called implied consent which
means if you find someone unconscious
you can start cpr without getting
consent in snow white's case she was
unconscious and unresponsive not only
did chris chomping
charming do nothing wrong it could have
been an open mouth kiss
in terms of mouth to mouth even worse he
could have touched her chest and still
been on the right side of the law
talking about chest compressions well
looks like we've got a rape apologist on
our hands here donna
pretty upsetting from you
you're banned for the show you should be
ashamed um
and uh another comment says please tell
me you're being sarcastic when you're
talking about the disney movies no i
i never i never engage in sarcasm is
beneath me
um and i would never do that on the show
and so if you listen to the show
yesterday the daily cancellation where i
was canceling a whole bunch of disney
movies
um not at all sarcastic uh
another comment says your views on
marriage are absurd
absurd what were my views on marriage
that i expressed oh
so my view on marriage as expressed
yesterday was that uh
you should stay married and stay true to
your vows
you know bill gates and his wife are
getting divorced after
27 years and when they're both in their
mid to late 60s
almost three decades of marriage they're
getting divorced because they they want
to grow as people individually
they feel like they can't grow together
anymore my view
is that you made a vow a promise and you
should keep it
and uh you should stay married and work
through your problems and what you're
telling me is that
not only do you disagree but you think
that's an absurd view it's a
it's an absurd view that married people
should
keep their promises
all right another one says pit bulls are
designed to be ferocious and
overprotective it's an armament and to
ban them would be an infringement oh
come on
come on now you say the pit bulls count
as a as a weapon under the second
amendment
well you know you can't like if that's
your argument it's like they're two
different arguments here
one is that they're a weapon just like a
gun
and so you have a right to have a pit
bull you have a right to bear pit bulls
there's that argument the other argument
is that they're actually harmless and
they're cute and cuddly and there's
nothing
you know and they're not going to hurt
you like it kind of seems like you have
to choose
one argument or the other and i'm i'm
getting both and i don't quite
can't quite figure out how to put all
those together um
and finally joshua says talking about my
video yesterday that video is like a
conservative ink boomer's wet dream
it's got it all everything from a chance
to call someone libitard or demon rat
to democrats are the real racists to
back the blue
to look at this based minority this
probably is getting hell attraction on
facebook
i literally said none of those things in
the video not one single one of those
things did i say
although i do think we should back the
blue but i didn't use any of those
phrases
so that's always my favorite criticism
when i'm criticized for things that i
didn't say at all you know try to i say
enough
things on a daily basis that you that if
you're looking for a reason to criticize
like try to just choose from the
category of things i actually said
i give you a lot of options things have
been growing like crazy here at the
the daily wire and uh we're expanding a
lot of exciting things going on
we know we've got the movie deal with
gina carano we launched the show with
candace owens
uh we released our first feature film
all this stuff that's just the first six
months a lot more to do
um in the months and years ahead but we
want to make sure we continue to include
you in our future plans
and one way that we do that is making
sure that we that we bring
in our shows products and services
that not only we love but that you will
love as well so
in order to better enable us to do that
please go to dailywire.comwalsh and fill
out my
audience survey to tell tell us a little
bit more about yourself
uh and then so that we can figure out
what kind of sponsors to bring to you
and to sweeten the whole experience
and uh and give you a little bit of
incentive go to
you when you complete the survey you're
entered to win a 1 000 gift card
now here's the thing you can only
complete the survey once and be entered
in for that um
that gift card but that's per show so
after you do my survey you could go
listen to ben shapiro michael knowles
andrew glavin get access to their
surveys as well
and you get a lot of chances to get that
gift card so make sure you go there and
do that right now
also if you didn't catch last night's
episode of candice don't worry you could
still watch the full interview with her
and president donald trump
if you're a daily wire member they
discuss everything from the media's
attacks against him and melania to
whether he's considering
another presidential run in 2024 if you
haven't joined daily wire yet hurry now
because this is your
last chance to get 25 off a new
membership with code candace
that code goes away on what is it this
thursday may 6th
so that's tomorrow or it's today what is
today it's tomorrow right anyway
you don't have a lot of chances so go
right now dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25 off
now let's get to our daily cancellation
our daily cancellation today has evolved
quite a bit
um or maybe it's more true to say that
it has
metamorphosed into a beautiful
ill-tempered butterfly however you want
to put it
i had planned today to cancel the cia
for its
now infamous woke recruitment ad
featuring a female cia agent who says
that she
is quote a cisgender millennial a woman
of color and
intersectional she also says that her
existence is not a box checking exercise
even as she proceeds to check every box
she can
now all of this is extremely stupid
worse than stupid when you consider that
the cia is recruiting people
who'd be better suited teaching gender
theory at portland community college
where all the students should attend for
free says jill biden
but the worst part of the ad is when she
boasts about her generalized anxiety
disorder
this is a someone working for the cia
who's bragging about the fact that they
have anxiety disorder
and she includes it as one of the
identity boxes to check
so on her victimhood resume anxiety
disorder is listed right alongside a
woman of color and intersectional and
all the rest of it
this is what we've done in our society
we have turned things like anxiety into
mental disorders and then made mental
disorders trendy
something that people like this woman
quite literally advertise
and that's what sent me off in a
different direction as i thought about
it
i became less interested in the cia ad
and and more interested in this issue of
anxiety
and what we in modern culture have made
of it and that's what prompted me to
tweet the following thought last night
i said uh quote quoting myself one of
the worst things to happen in modern
times is the medicalization of the human
condition
now people who experience anxiety think
they're sick they aren't
anxiety is a fundamental fact of human
existence it is not a disease
that's what i wrote that's what i
believe we have set out to medicalize
and diseasify
every aspect of the human condition
every difficult emotion
every unpleasant personality trait
that's why the dsm now has something
like 300 mental disorders listed and
over 50 million adults in this country
have been diagnosed with at least one of
them
now as you might expect that opinion
provoked an intense
and almost entirely negative reaction
almost entirely negative public reaction
i should qualify i have gotten a lot of
private messages from people whispering
their agreement with me
saying hey i agree with you attaboy
thumbs up
but in public almost everyone who's
chimed in and contributed to the
discussion has been of the opinion that
i am wrong and not only wrong but a
filthy worthless piece
of human dirt for even daring to say
something like this out loud
or tweet it out loud now i am saying it
out loud because the one way to ensure
that i keep saying something
and keep saying it louder and louder is
to demand that i stop saying it
yes that is that's that's the maturity
level for me
you tell me just to stop saying it i'm
going to say it louder that's the way i
work
now i'd like to explain my point of view
a little bit uh but i want to be clear
before i do that this explanation
is in no way an apology i don't
apologize
at all i'm really happy that i said what
i said
and i couldn't have been more right
about it and if you're someone who
reacts to an
honest opinion by screaming and crying
and ranting and raving
the problem is you you in fact owe me an
apology for being so unreasonable and
annoying
so i accept your apology you are
forgiven
now let's move on to the actual issue
and as far as that goes a few points i
want to make number one
i have been accused of stigmatizing
mental illness with this opinion i'm
told the same whenever i argue that adhd
is not a real mental illness which it
isn't
not a real disorder which it isn't but
um
what i'm doing is exactly the opposite
of stigmatizing
what i'm saying is that anxiety is an
inevitable part of being human it comes
with our consciousness
and self-awareness stigmatize no to
stigmatize is to say that it's weird or
embarrassing
if anything calling it a mental disorder
is stigmatizing
i'm also not minimizing anxiety i'm not
stigmatizing or minimizing
just because it comes with being human
doesn't mean that it's any less painful
difficult you know
sometimes overwhelming neither am i
saying that those struggling with their
anxiety shouldn't seek help again
just because anxiety is human doesn't
mean that we shouldn't that we that we
should wallow helplessly in it
so i'm not stigmatizing i'm not
minimizing and i'm not saying that
people shouldn't get help
i'm simply arguing that we have made a
category
error we have placed anxiety along with
many other human emotions
and experiences like for example despair
into a medical box when it doesn't
belong there
two the idea that anxiety is a
fundamental fact of human existence a
defining fact
actually is not new or bold i wish i
could take credit for having this bold
interesting new opinion i don't
only the last 18 seconds or so did we
decide as a
country as a society
to start treating these things as
psychiatric disorders prior to the
medicalization push
anxiety was a subject for philosophers
and theologians and other great minds
this is not an argument from authority
my critics are the ones making arguments
from authority i'll get to that in a
minute but
my point is simply that what i'm saying
about anxiety
has been said or something very close to
it has been said by many people much
smarter than myself and much smarter
than you probably
all throughout history that doesn't mean
that i'm right
but it does mean that if you're shocked
by the idea that i present here
if you react to it like it's absurd or
outlandish
then i have to suspect that you really
haven't thought much about it or read
anything about it
if you'd spend any significant time
reflecting on anxiety and reading what
others have said about it throughout
history
then you certainly would have
encountered my point of view many times
and should not therefore be recoiling in
shock and horror
if you are recoiling shocking heart then
consider the possibility
that you haven't given this topic much
thought
number three i have been told that i am
not qualified to give my opinion on this
subject because i'm not a doctor but i
note with interest
that almost all of the people telling me
that i'm not qualified because i lack a
medical degree
also themselves lack a medical degree
turns out that you don't need a doctor
you don't need to be a doctor to have an
opinion you need to be a doctor to have
an opinion that differs from their own
that is an argument from authority and
it's also ad hoc
childish and stupid besides my point
here once again
is that this is not a medical
to demand my medical credentials is to
beg the question
you're expecting me to abide by your
premise but i'm rejecting your premise
that's the whole point of the arguments
doctors may be experts on medical
conditions but they're not experts on
the human
condition i'm not sure that anyone can
be an expert on that per se because they
could only experience their own humanity
and not anybody else's but i do think
that some people are blessed with wisdom
that gives them greater insight into the
subject than others
i don't think that doctors often have
that insight actually i think it's a big
problem
that doctors know about medical
conditions but they have it seems often
have very little understanding of human
nature and the human condition
so for a greater understanding of that
of human nature in the human condition
for that you have to look to those great
philosophers theologians and other men
others mentioned earlier four finally um
there's a version of my argument that
would garner much wider approval and
agreement i think
if i had simply said that anxiety
disorder is over diagnosed
most people would probably agree say the
same about adhd
and depression and other similar things
uh and most people agree
if you say it's over diagnosed even
people who have been diagnosed
will usually agree though most of them
will say that other people have been
misdiagnosed not themselves so it's a
very odd problem apparently mental
disorders are being massively
misdiagnosed
but no individual person has been
misdiagnosed
quite a riddle isn't it now i think we
end up here because the general problem
is just undeniable as already mentioned
there are around
300 diagnosable mental disorders and
counting
300 different ways that your mind can be
considered disordered
sick diseased and now 50 million adults
and 17 million children have been
diagnosed with at least one of them
that doesn't make any intuitive sense
how can so many people
be mentally ill at a certain point if so
many people have disordered minds
doesn't the word disordered begin to
lose its meaning
to call something disordered you have to
have some idea of what the proper order
is so what is the properly ordered
mind and who has it because pretty soon
we get to the point where
nobody has one and if everybody has a
disorder
then it would seem like nobody does
the word just doesn't mean anything
anymore now this problem is apparent i
think to a lot of people and yet few
people want to really think
about why this is happening how it has
happened
how to prevent it from happening all
we're allowed to do
all that most people will allow
themselves to do is look at the problem
from 30 000 feet speak about it in very
broad terms and then ultimately shrug
their shoulders and
move on and do nothing about it to get
any more specific
to really dig down deep into the issue
is dangerous and upsetting and it
requires you to trample over
a whole lot of sacred cows so
let's trample them my view is that
mental disorders
are widely wildly over diagnosed and
misdiagnosed
because some of the most commonly
diagnosed mental disorders
do not belong in that category at all
anxiety is not the only example of this
but it's the one we're discussing today
when you take something like anxiety
which is absolutely essential to the
human experience
and you declare that when it's felt to a
certain degree
or reaches a certain amount it's
disordered
and transforms from a human emotion to a
mental illness
you have opened up a floodgate that you
cannot close
you could say that anxiety is only
disordered when it causes problems in
this or that area of your life or is
experienced
for this or that reason or in this or
that way or whatever else but ultimately
these standards are going to always be
arbitrary and subjective
by definition it's not like diagnosing a
tumor or cardiovascular disease you're
attempting to diagnose
the content of someone's consciousness
you are diagnosing a thought process
and yes anxiety is a thought process now
you might say oh it has physical causes
so on and so forth
it's a thought in other words a
non-thinking being
cannot be experiencing anxiety
if a if a if a person or being is not
thinking anything then it doesn't make
any sense to say that they're having
anxiety
anxiety is a thought process and that's
what you're diagnosing
it's a normal thought process one of the
most normal most fundamental thought
processes
when you start slapping medical labels
on normal
if painful human thoughts and emotions
eventually you'll have slapped a label
on
every emotion and every person and we
we are well on our way to that point the
only way to stop it
is to radically rethink our whole
approach to mental illness
we have to start reorganizing the
categories in a major way
we have to consider the possibility that
not everything which causes pain
is a sickness not every source of agony
is a disorder if we're not willing to
think about that or even to talk about
it
then the tide of medicalization and
pharmaceutical intervention will
continue to rise
until everyone is drowning in it
and for that reason today the cia is
cancelled
they weren't going to escape i was
coming back around to them
and so they're still canceled um and uh
you know anxiety disorder is also
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. today on the
ben shapiro show the facebook oversight
board says that the company was right to
ban trump
war breaks out inside the house gop over
liz cheney and the democratic party
continues to promote economic
immigration and coveted idiocy that's
today on the ben shapiro shall give it a
listen